- So I always like to wrap
things up with something cool
or unusual from social
media. But this week,
instead of sharing what I
am liking, we are leaving it
to the viewers, highlighting
our most viral moments ever.
So this is what you're liking.
(upbeat, happy music)
-  Woooo!
- This one goes back to a
very cool hour when I got to
hang out with the one and
only Dave Grohl. I love him.
Obviously, we talked a lot
about music, and he revealed
something that really surprised
me about one of his songs.
(Audience claps)
One of your most popular songs
is "Learn to Fly". I love it.
You wrote on it, "Looking
to the sky to save me,
looking for a sign of life,
looking for something to
help me burn out bright."
Now this is, once again, it comes back
to that whole thing
that I love that you do.
For me, whenever I'm
listening to your lyrics,
maybe you didn't write it like this,
but I love that soaring feeling
like that whole thing I get like visually.
I always love your lyrics
too, because it's like paint.
You paint such a great visual for me.
And I love that.
But it kind of, again, to me is like
a little dark and a little light.
It's always there, like a shared world
which I guess is life.
- I don't wanna burst your bubble.
- Okay. I'm gonna drink my tea.
And you're like, so this was about
- At the time I wanted to become a pilot.
I was like, I wanted to learn to fly.
Like, I did. I mean,
like that's it.
Like, I was like,
I was,
I hate that.
- Oh!
I know, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
- Oh my God!
- I got these video tapes.
- It's so literal!
- I was reading all these books.
- It really is.
- It's so literal.
- I'm sorry.
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God. And in my brain,
- It's what I'm talking about!
- I'm singing it because I
wanna learn how to be a pilot
- In my brain
- You're singing it because like I'm
so inspired by life and whatever.
(Audience laughs)
See!